il ya quelques jours je vous parlais de
l'iphone 11 qui est là maintenant parler
de l'iphone 11 promax qui se situe juste
là lors l'iphone on se prend max
il ya un truc qui équipera intéressant
ce que je suis bien nets moyens
il ya un truc il prend intéressant c'est
que cet iphone vous permet de voyager
dans le temps est-ce que vous êtes prêts
regardez bien à temps ces jeux vous je
vous le fais bien parce que là faut pas
que hacker jonah loop voir des bien
pensants vous êtes prêts 2010neuf
attention parce 2017 on les entend on
retourne dans le futur fin dans le
présent par 2019 2017 grâce à l'iphone
on se promet axe à l'iphone on se trouve
ou alors carrément aller faute 11
on peut voyager dans le temps merci
apple néanmoins au lieu de ce design qui
est un petit peu old school qu'on
connaissait tant qu'os en 2017 et jean
dans l'absolu bon vous deviez pas une
trappe
il pourra bien au vu de ce que de push
la concurrence en face est-ce que cet
iphone 11 promax est intéressant en 2019
est ce qu'au final ce module photo que
je trouvais un petit peu bab louta un
peu comme tout le monde au début
est-ce qu'il est bien est ce qu'il est
intéressant qu'un veau cet iphone 11
promax est-ce qu'il faut l'acheter
est-ce qu'il faut se positionner et au
final est-ce qu'il tient ses promesses
c'est on regarde webinar
[Musique]
je coupe un peu je vous emmène
aujourd'hui on est lisbonne alors je
sais on parle pas du tout de lisbonne on
n'est pas en voyage pour parler de
lisbonne monde en parle demain parce que
on est là pour vos propos il ya plein de
choses à dire par contre vous et vous
parle d'autre chose j'en profite
justement d'être en voyage pour parler
justement est bien de problématiques de
langue si typiquement à lisbonne au
portugal
on parle pas un mot de portugais est
alors souvent il ya des gens qui vont
vous parlez anglais ça c'est cool parce
que je parle anglais par contre pour lui
c'est pas du tout ça
et justement aujourd'hui sept vidéos
sponsorisées par babel pour vous parler
de solution pour apprendre à parler des
langues très rapidement je vous montre
ça vous allez voir c'est très facile
très pratique et ça pourrait vous sauver
la vie si comme moi vous voyagez et que
vous ne maîtrisez pas particulièrement
l'idée c'est que vous avez votre
application qui est là que vous pouvez
l'utiliser très facilement leur bien
évidemment là c'est une application sur
android mais vous l'avez aussi sur un os
et aussi sur votre ordinateur comme ça
vous pouvez où que vous soyez il soit
dans le métro dans le bus entre deux
cours au travail sur une pause valeur
chez vous le soir
quel que soit le device vous pouvez
venir à prendre directement ayant alors
là j'avais mis de l'allemand mais j'ai
plein d'autres langues rdv ici je
dormais paramètres je vais dans mélanger
ce que choisir on va se prendre le
portugais il ya plein de langues à
regarder la joyeuse année l'allemand
l'anglais le danois l'espagnol l'italien
et norvégiens y en a plus y en a des
tonnes donc là vous avez franchement de
quoi faire on va se prendre le portugais
personnellement je ne parle pas un mot
de portugais et ça me permet justement
de bosser ça l'idée c'est que vous avez
sur votre page d'accueil alors déjà je
suis un peu largué et j'ai plein de
leçons la voyait au niveau découverte
cours un g12 de son pouvoir commencer ce
niveau là douze leçons sur le court 1
100 courts 2 g13 leçon j'ai ensuite des
révisions alors pour réviser faut déjà
avoir appris la zone mm justement
profiter du fait d'être d'être à
lisbonne et puis ensuite vous avez votre
profil vous allez pouvoir voir vos
leçons vos révisions voir où vous en
êtes et ça c'est vraiment cool
oui tot brasey excuse moi j'ai des
school pas voilà comme ça je peux
apprendre la langue c'est cool ça vous
permet de parler la langue pas de façon
scolaire n'est comme au frais dans le
payant pour pouvoir très rapidement
pouvoir parler communiquer avec
l'autochtone en 15 minutes vous avez
fait une leçon pour être hyper efficace
et très rapide il ya bien évidemment
plein de leçons et plein de sujets
différents la grammaire du vocabulaire
vous pouvez écouter répéter soyez
rassurés si vous demandez si babel c'est
sérieux s'il ya du monde qui travaillent
derrière qui connaît bien la langue il
ya 150 experts dans la team comme ça
vous êtes tranquille et maîtrisent la
langue pouvez y aller les yeux fermés
vous dirai pas de bêtises lorsque vous
serez à l'étranger vous invite à venir
tester essayer de découvrir cette
solution label vous ai mis un lien en
bas dans la description vous m'en direz
des nouvelles pour l'instant on retourne
au studio et on va se parler de l'iphone
11 gros max honda se concentrent un
petit peu mentalement il ya plein de
choses à dire la première chose c'est la
promesse et les promesses que nous font
apple pour cet iphone à savoir un design
réinventer pour l'arrière je suis
d'accord pour l'avant on repassera on se
réinvente en 2010 est probablement dans
2019 l'avant n'est clairement pas du
tout réinventer ou plat en aviculture en
fait c'est toujours la même chose par
contre pour l'arrière je suis d'accord
c'est clairement réinventer une
performance accrue avec la puce à 13
bionique ça marche même d'ailleurs très
bien une meilleure autonomie alors
meilleure autonomie au niveau d'une plus
grosse batterie à l'intérieur on est
quasiment quatre villes ayant permis une
meilleure gestion de la batterie bien
évidemment grâce à la puce à 13 bionique
mais grâce aussi à un os qui
complètement optimisé ça je vous en
parle également de facto instant et puis
bien évidemment toute la partie photo la
promesse que nous fait un peu là dessus
si effectivement d'excellentes photos
mais aussi d'excellentes vidéo alors moi
vous savez j'étais comme tous mes petits
camarades à me dire mais franchement
c'est quoi ce design c'est pas très beau
c'est au final assez mal intégrés puis
c'est quoi cette idée de nous mettre ces
espèces de plaques de cuisson comme ça
je sais pas si vous soulevez j'avais
fait une vidéo ya quelques mois qu'il
avait intitulé apple ne fait pas ça
c'est une très mauvaise idée apple parce
qu'effectivement ça pas terrible à côté
de ça lorsque les premiers rendus ou les
premières fuites que les premières
créations avaient été faites le petit
bloc là était tout noir donc on avait
une espèce de truc un gros carré noir un
peu bizarre et ça faisait un peu tâche
là ce qu'on voit c'est que le rendu est
différent on a ici toujours un dos en
verre qui est à côté un petit peu plus
mat et la lah cette partie là est assez
brillant si original parce que
du coup pour coup ça ne laisse pas de
traces de doigts donc ça je trouve ça
vraiment vraiment vraiment bien c'est
très original et pour le coup très bien
réussi par contre et si effectivement il
y aura des traces de doigts et des
virements là on doit pas venir poser son
doigt
maintenant il ya un truc est vraiment
assez incroyable c'est la magie du
cerveau par quand on regarde au début on
se dit genre ah ouais je sais pas je
suis pas sûr
et puis maintenant pas mal ça croyez moi
c'est la magie du cerveau non pas que je
revienne sur ce que j'ai dit parce que
c'est vrai que c'est changeant ses
différents sens c'est très bizarre quand
on regarde comme ça mais on s'habitue
c'est comme tout on finit par s'habituer
aux choses et au final ce truc là même
si c'est un peu bizarre
eh bien je conçois pas si moche je vous
jure c'est vraiment tout cas c'est
dingue il faut l'avoir entre ses mains
il faut pouvoir manipuler vont pouvoir
se rendre compte maintenant le truc que
j'aime pas trop est-ce que c'est pas que
c'est horrible c'est que j'ai du mal
effectivement a trouvé ça intéressant
c'est toujours cette grande encore avec
faith heidi en 2019 ses sauts 2017
ça c'est vraiment dommage le look
général de ce smartphone est vraiment
sow 2017
on retrouve la même chose le cadre en
alu les mêmes positionnement des boutons
à côté ça c'est un truc qui marche alors
pourquoi changer quelque chose qui
marche ce serait prendre un risque
je peux comprendre qu'apple continue à
rester là dessus moi tant que je vais
appeler regretté maintenant c'est le
poids ce smartphone est extrêmement
lourd il fait 226 gran croyez-moi ce
n'est pas rien alors bien évidemment aux
aquilin grand format qu'il ait une plus
grande maîtrise tout ça tout ça tout ça
je suis d'accord mais il fait quand même
2 126 g ça lui confère du poids beaucoup
de poids et ça ou voyez je trouve ça un
peu dommage par contre iphone il un dos
en verre un courant vert même si
effectivement il prend pas les traces de
doigts un grand verre qui peut
potentiellement se casser s'il tombe
directement sur des cailloux son camp ce
soit donc je vous conseille vraiment une
fois de plus de mieux protéger alors
vous avez deux solutions il y en a
plusieurs mais moi ça que je vous
concède de mon partenaire rhino chine
puisque si vous me suivez vous savez que
j'ai un partenariat avec rhinochill qui
a un éventail regardez comme je laisse
un éventail de produits et à ses
couleurs bien évidemment protection
d'écran parce que vous avez un écran il
faut protéger c'est très important mais
vous avez également un truc assez cool
c'est le cras diable up
en fait l'idée c'est que votre
smartphone si vous aimez le dos si vous
voulez continuer à le voir et en
profiter que vous ne voulez pas venir le
cacher eh bien vous mettez ce qu'on
appelle un petit crash garde ça vient
vous le protéger à l'avancé vous le
protéger
hier vous profiter quand même
effectivement de votre dos qui est sympa
donc ça c'est la première solution et
vous avez aussi ce qu'ils appellent
coque solide fluide solide solide suite
jci mali dire des fois je demande ce qui
se passe vous venez poser votre
smartphone à l'intérieur bon c'est une
coque de protection
voyez ça bouffe un cadre un peu plus
grand vous retrouvez votre appareil
photo ici mais par contre il y protéger
de tous les côtés et ça c'est plutôt
coup d'ailleurs vous avez 10 % de remise
avec le code monsieur grezet tous marqué
en bas d'un description ne vais pas y
aller ça pourrait vous sauver la vie
l'écran reste le même par rapport aux
vestes de l'année dernière 6,5 pouces
2688 par une île de 132 pixels à 458
pixels pas plus le point qui est cool
c'est qu'effectivement c'est un écran
qui est vachement bien la qualité est
vraiment top
extrêmement lumineux des contrastes sont
géniaux les noix absolue on a vraiment
d'écran de très très très très grande
qualité toujours regretter cette grande
encoches sur le côté que je trouve
qu'effectivement qui est so 2010 hedge
fund une fois de plus on a des bordures
noires mais qui par contre elle ne me
dérange pas ce qui est vraiment génial
c'est cet écran est superbe et vraiment
très très bon vous le mettez à
l'extérieur il marche parfaitement bien
et ce qui est génial c'est aussi l'audio
écoutez moi ça vous avez vu son stéréo
il est approuvé
ici les haut parleurs là haut parleurs
là vous avez un seau fait vraiment bien
bonne qualité qui puissant ça je trouve
ça vraiment vraiment extrêmement
couleurs l'expérience multimédia donc
tout simplement génial que vous
regardiez du contenu vidéo que vous
alliez sur youtube netflix sur tous les
réseaux vous vouliez mêmes pour jouer à
des jeux c'est top
parce que derrière vous avez ce qu'il
faut en terme de performance merci et la
puce après ce bionic de me permettre
d'aller toujours plus vite d'aller
toujours mieux en termes de performances
en plus j'ai 4 gigas de ram derrière ça
marche parfaitement bien c'est très bien
maîtrisé ça c'est vraiment cool parce
que ça apporte quand même beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup plus de performances
jeu convient parfaitement aux direz mais
de qui se moque t-on 4 gigas de ram
on va se dire que dans le nouvel iphone
on a 4 gigas de ram dans le modèle le
plus puissant qui coûte 1200 euros alors
que dans le one + 7 pro dans le modèle
que j'aime en tout cas j'ai 12 giga de
ram
ça veut dire que j'en ai trois fois plus
que sur le modèle qui coûte une blinde
alors oui effectivement je suis d'accord
mais c'est pas forcément le chiffre qui
compte ce qui compte derrière c'est
l'optimisation il faut savoir qu'apple
vous avez des composants qui sont hyper
optimisé
la puce apple l' os apple le matériel
apple même si ils font appel à des
fournisseurs pour du matériel à
l'intérieur gagne tout est extrêmement
bien un briquet maîtrisé c'était que
vous avez une machine qui marche
parfaitement bien merveilleusement bien
et croyez moi avec ses 4 gigas de ram
vous avez une bécane t extrêmement
fluide et sa as cannes toujours très
impressionnant
vous allez pouvoir naviguer comme vous
voulez ça marche bien c'est extrêmement
flou on se retrouve avec un os qui est
vraiment optimisé une machine qui
optimise et qui ne rame pas parce que
cette puce à 13 bionic est de vous
apporter un voudriez bien en termes
d'autonomie
deux performances de tout ce que vous
voulez c'est selon apple le processeur
le stock le plus performant du marché
devant la concurrence
en tout cas pour moi en terme de jeu en
terme d'expérience de fluidité et
d'autonomie c'est vraiment vraiment cool
et je vous disais vous avez une très
grosse batterie ça change pour une fois
chez apple
une bataille qui fait quasiment 4000
milliampères heures ce qui est quand
même colossal surtout chez apple on nous
annonce effectivement cinq heures de
plus qu'avec l'iphone 10 s max de
l'année dernière c'est pas rien il faut
savoir qu'il ya un gap entre l'iphone
10r et l'iphone 11 cette année il ya un
gap de 1h à dire un petit plus de une
heure ce qui est quand même non
négligeable là vous arriver entre
l'iphone 10 s max et l'iphone 11 prend
max + 5 heures d'autonomie
c'est franchement démentiel c'est vrai
que cet iphone je n'ai pas mis à genoux
je n'ai pas mieux je leur fait qu'il ya
un moment il faudra changer
évidemment ça dépend une fois de plus de
vos usages de ce que vous allez en faire
si vous êtes tout le temps dessus et si
vous voulez deux jours vous avez deux
jours bien évidemment si vous mourides à
mort il ya un moment où ça va être
compliqué mais dans l'absolu ça marche
merveilleusement bien
autre point qui est intéressant vous
avez un chargeur de 18 watts qui inclut
directement dans la boîte alors on
pourrait se dire effectivement charger
18 par rapport à ce qu'ils ont trouvées
chez d'autres constructeurs android à la
concurrence ça pourrait paraître un
petit peu petit bras
mais une fois de plus on va se situer on
est chez apple apple ne fait pas
particulièrement ce genre de choses en
règle générale vous avez des chargeurs
qui sont assez lents la sarre charges
assez bien assez rapidement ça s'écoute
d'autant plus que vous avez du
changement cette année vous avez
effectivement un port lightning ici mais
l'autre côté vous avez de l'usbc faut
savoir effectivement que la gamme pro
tout cas ce qu'il devient
pro chez apple est une gamme tous
brochand d'huez mais c'est un ipad pro
un macbook pro vous avez que la
connectique usb c'est donc ça paraît
logique effectivement vous avez du
lightning usb c'est comme ça vous pouvez
brancher votre iphone directement dans
votre macbook pro et ça c'est plutôt
cool sahibly d'utiliser un dock mais là
où l'iphone devient intéressant c'est
effectivement au niveau de l'appareil
photo arrière au-delà du fait qu'on aime
ou qu'on n'aime pas le le module photo
arrière tel qu'il est positionné un
petit peu en triant il faut savoir vous
allez quand même des choses qui marchent
et qui marche parfaitement bien chez
apple vous êtes toujours sur du 12
mégapixels vous avez pour l'instant deux
capteurs qui sont identiques à ce que
vous a trouvé sur l'iphone 11 c'est à
dire 12 mégapixels grand temps que tu
ouvre à f 1.8 qui est votre capteur
principal et vous avez derrière un ultra
grand-angle toujours 12 mégapixels qui
ouvre à f 2.4 qui est un grand-angle de
120° vous avez exactement la même chose
d'un côté comme de l'autre à savoir que
là dessus vous avez un petit truc en
plus
non des moindres et qui est intéressant
c'est un 12 mégapixels une fois de plus
d'un téléobjectif qui ouvre à f 2.0 et
que vous permet de faire un zoom optique
x 2 et un zoom numérique x 10 est à
noter qu'à l'avant vous effectivement
votre caméra trop d'eps 12 mégapixels
qui ouvre à f 2.2 la caméra principale
la première à 12 mégapixels du
grand-angle et celles qui marchent le
mieux qu'ils donnent le meilleur rendu
rendu que je trouve pour ma part assez
naturelle des photos de qualité
on est assez proche de ce qu'on retrouve
dans la réalité on n'est pas sûr saturé
on apparaître qu'ils sont sûrs
contrastée on note les photos qui tire
légèrement sur le jaune mais ça c'est un
petit peu la colorimétrie apple on se
retrouve dans ce qui se fait de mieux en
terme de photos sur le marché en termes
de photophones alors effectivement il ex
marine qui marche très très bien chez
android pétron pro notamment le google
pixels 3 ya des choses qui sont vraiment
bien maîtrisée samsung galaxy s 10 et se
disent plus longtemps vous avez le
deuxième capteur luttera grand-angle qui
lui sera un peu moins bon en terme de
rendu dès lors vous avez moins de
lumière ça marchera moins bien par
contre ce qui est vraiment très bon très
impressionnant c'est vous allez
retrouver
elle a même colorimétrie entre les
photos prises sur un capteur principal
et les photos prises sans capteur
grand-angle ça c'est assez difficile en
fait à faire si vous voulez mais d'un
point de vue logiciel d'un point de vue
matériel tout est parfaitement bien
harmonisé après vous avez troisième
capteurs le zoom x 2 alors le zoom x 2
est assez intéressant permet d'avoir un
rendu qui sera moins bruyant que ce que
vous allez avoir avec le zoom numérique
bien évidemment de l'iphone 11 ça me
paraît quand même relativement
gic ça marche bien mais dès lors que
vous allez vouloir monter jusqu'aux zoom
x 10 là par contre zoug faut disent
c'est pas terrible ça rajoute beaucoup
de bruit pour ma part rendu des photos
je vous dis j'adore gervais son capteur
principal le 12 mégapixels j'adore
vraiment le rendu que ça très très juste
les couleurs sont vraiment sympas là on
est sur l'ultra grand-angle ça marche
également
et là on est sur le téléobjectif zoom x
2 alors bien évidemment la faute aux
îles tokelau particulière c'est un
reflet dans une flaque d'eau mais je
trouve ça bien franchement non on
continue avec le grand-angle la caméra
principale regarder le ciel et bien pas
cramé on a un bon rendu on a un bon
rendu de la façade en bas vous avez un
peu moins de lumière mais ça marche
aussi vraiment bien on a un rendu qui
est très juste de tous les côtés on
arrive ensuite sur l' ultra grand-angle
pareil c'est très bien bien rendu on est
une légère déformation au niveau du
grand angle mais bon ça ne paraît pas
complètement dingue non plus ça marche
et à ce titre était l'objectif avec le
zoom x 2 qui est bien le rendu est cool
et regarder le ciel
on a un beau rendu et que si l usage d r
marche parfaitement bien par une caméra
principale grand-angle et là avec le
zoom on retrouve du détail bien
évidemment je suis doué mais on a du
détail
kendra principal il sera grand angle le
ciel assez légèrement cramer là je pense
qu'il était placé les vrilles et là ça
paraît bien là c'est légèrement un peu
cramé je vous dis lui très grand-angle
et quand même moins qualitatif mais
fonctionne également hélas avec le
téléobjectif sang continue caméra
principale
il sera grand temps de regarder à les
couleurs dans le ciel c'est vachement
sympa comme ça dans la lumière en halo
le soleil qui est là donc c'est pour ça
que sur cette photo là on avait cet
effet là c'est parce que vous les avez
le soleil est juste là et là on le
retrouve bien et la télé objectif zoom x
2 ça marche merveilleusement bien non
c'est elliott pris de dos calera ultra
grand-angle et ensuite zoug 3 2 me
permettre ça nous permet d'avoir des
rendus qui sont vraiment hyper kelly
même lorsque vous allez vous rapprocher
de fleurs comme ça directement de la
défense qui sont vraiment vraiment hypra
cool caméra principale jouffre de on
récupère quand même vachement de détail
au centre regard des landes a les poils
c'est vraiment cool qu'elle est la
principale
il sera devant angle zoom x 2 et la
chercher avec les une fois 10 on
récupère de bruit ces pages et j'aimais
ça fonctionne
il ajoutera que les effets un peu de
concots jours avec le soleil en face on
retrouve bien tous les détails au niveau
du ciel on voit les feuilles ici sur le
côté on voit bien en bas rien et cramer
c'est bien équilibré
ça m'a parfaitement bien c'est vraiment
vraiment cool avec la caméra cloud
de pareils on récupère bien les détails
c'est plutôt bien fait assez bien
réalisé
j sera grand temps que ça marche aussi
caméra principale il sera longtemps gle
joue pas de caméra principale ville soit
deux caméras principal une fois deux
pour les photos prises en plein jour que
vous avez beaucoup de lumière ça marche
très très bien
il ya une très belle maîtrise entre ces
trois capteurs photo judy une fois de
plus le capteur principal pour moi celui
qui marche le mieux quel meilleur rendu
et qui peut se classer parmi les
meilleurs appareils photos du marché
aujourd'hui ultra grand-angle c'est moi
ça le zoom x 2 ça marche maintenant et
un truc qui est aussi intéressant c'est
la photo de nuit parce que même si en
règle générale on fait pas beaucoup de
photos la nuit au tout cas c'est pas le
critère principal ça permet vraiment de
montrer l'évolution les puissances
technologiques de la marque est ce
qu'ils sont capables de faire pour
innover et là on a un truc qui est quand
même assez bien alors assez bien leur
causer son capteur principal
je vais vous arrivez sont ultra
grand-angle c'est beaucoup moins bien
c'est beaucoup plus brouillon je joue
une fois de fonctionne mais c'est parce
qu'à mieux pour moi ce cas mieux cette
capteur principal qu'on n'aura pas un
rendu qui sera aussi bon que ce qu'on
peut avoir par exemple avec un samsung
galaxy s qui souhaitent se disent plus
ou alors avec un doodle pixels 3 au
niveau des lumières c'est pas génial par
contre ce qui est bien c'est que ça vous
fera des photos qui seront optimisés on
a vraiment un rang d'une nuit ça vous
crée pas d espèce de faux jour c'est
assez juste que vous arrivez son ultra
grand-angle samar tout de suite beaucoup
moins bien on capte beaucoup moins la
lumière ce qui paraît quand même assez
normal puisque ouverture de f 2.4 les
zoom optique x 2 fonctionne pas trop mal
on ouvre à f 2.0
c'est pas mal mais c'est pas non plus
génial ce qu'il en serait le joug d'une
fois de plus c'est capteur principal
capteur principal du très grand-angle
une fois ou deux mais on a de la lumière
donc ça marche
là c'est pareil capteur principal une
fois deux téléobjectifs capteur
principal et c'est là que ça devient
vraiment intéressant parce que ici il
faisait vraiment vraiment vraiment noir
donc on avait trois secondes
d'exposition je vous montrais du point
de vue logiciel comment ça marche ça m'a
bien récupérer le ciel par contre ça m'a
un petit peu effectivement tout cramer
ici la voyez au niveau des éclairages la
compensation est pas génial par rapport
à ce qu'ils sont tous cas la concurrence
c'est pas ce qui marche le mieux c'est
qu'on arrive sont ultra grand-angle il
ya plus personne ça marche plus bas il
n'y a pas de lumière donc ça ne marche
pas zoom x 2 fait son petit effet mais
ces pages est pareil dans un parc qui
sera grand temps que c'est pas terrible
une fois de ça fonctionne si 30 angle
ultra grand-angle on y voit absolument
plus rien toutefois deux ça marche
l'interface ios été retravaillé au
niveau de la photo c'est vachement cool
déjà ce qui est bien c'est les effets de
transitions radio il ya des effets de
transition zoom dézoom qui sont vraiment
vraiment très très joli alors je pas si
vous l'avez vu mais en fait ici là ce
que vous voyez sur le côté qu un peu
gris
c'est ce que pourrait vous proposer du
très grand-angle par contre ce qui va
seulement bien c'est que le mode nuit et
automatique vous n'avez pas de mot nous
vient chercher ici vous ne trouverez pas
de bonus des modes portrait panoramique
tout ce que vous voulez le mot nuit
détecter automatiquement on va couper la
lumière vous allez voir comment ça
marche lorsque je veux venir ajouté
lorsque je suis dans le noir comme ça
voyez on voit pas grand chose vous
montre n'y a pas beaucoup de lumière
dans la pièce on va beaucoup mieux avec
l'iphone 4 je veux le gh1 qu ici ce que
j'ai sur le côté j'ai un petit compteur
voyez sa marque 3 ou 2 et bien c'est le
temps d'exposition nécessaire l'iphone
va reconnaître si je le tiens la main ou
s'il est posé sur un trépied pour
adapter le temps d'exposition
mais lorsque jacques fuite hop j'ai
petit compteur qui défie la droite qui
met le temps restant hop et l'a ensuite
j'ai ma photo je clique et la voyage
affichage invendus est quand même
relativement pas mal je vous rappelle
qu'on voit quand même globalement pas
grand chose dans la pièce ça marche
plutôt bien alors c'est pas complètement
dingue hein bien évidemment il ya pas
beaucoup de lumière dans la pièce donc
on va pas voir le rendu le plus optimal
mais bon dans l'absolu ça marche
après il ya un autre point qui part ou
fille sim c'est la partie mode portrait
alors que c'est souvent là qu'on peut
voir la qualité d'un smartphone ça c'est
une photo que j'ai prise mois avec le
mode portrait lorsque vous venez zoomer
regarder au niveau des cheveux et bien
c'est pas hyper net c'est pas hyper
hyper fou bien d'autres smartphones qui
marche très bien pour des caméras tough
qui permet de mesurer la distance c'est
là où on voit qu'effectivement c'est un
flou logiciel c'est pas génial génial
pour moi ça c'est aussi le partir
travailler alors pour le coup ça
pourrait être un des points fort d'apple
maintenant y'a un truc qui marche très
très bien qui est vraiment bluffant
c'est la partie vidéo et notamment au
niveau de la stabilisation c'est pour
moi une des meilleures stabilisation du
marché que je trouve au niveau des
smartphones si ce n'est la meilleure
puisque un point qui est intéressant
c'est qu'on faisait une petite molette
et vous pouvez venir en maintenant vous
filmez vous venez zoomer vous dire
chercher alors attention lorsque vous
arrivez trop évolué comme ça vous
rajoute du bruit c'est pas terrible
regardez-vous nezu mais paf vous venez
dézoomer vous êtes sur l'ultra grand pan
l'équivalent de 13 mm ça marche vous
revenez sur votre caméra principale qui
est de 26 mm ça marche vous faites
vraiment ce que vous voulez que ça j'ai
testé une fois new york sur l'iphone on
sait exactement la même chose sauf que
vous avez pas effectivement le zoom
numérique mais on voit lorsque je suis
là attention
la fissure la caméra principale et hop
un jeu pas sur le téléobjectif on
retrouve de la stabilisation qu'on avait
un petit peu perdues si la voyez la
suisse en la caméra principale je
tremblais du mal à compenser et pas je
suis de l'autre côté c'est hyper
impressionnant
moi je suis un excellent crash test pour
ça son ultra grand-angle instable et pas
folle par contre des conneries ce
capteur principal c'est qu'on cherche
pas à zoomer aller dedans
et bien tout de suite c'est vachement à
égaliser
on arrive sur le téléobjectif s'est
stabilisé l'entre-deux il ya comme un
bon forcément ça c'est au niveau de la
star d'high tronic donc si vous cherchez
un excellent smartphone pour faire des
vidéos et bien croyez moi l'iphone 11
promax est vraiment vraiment vraiment
génial qu'on a une bonne qualité d'image
on peut filmer sur quatre cas à 60
images par seconde
on a une stabilisation qui est vraiment
bien que le fait de jouer avec cette
petite molette c'est vachement cool
c'est très intuitif le rendu est
qualitatif stabiliser vraiment je peux
que vous recommander cet iphone entre au
max a donc quasiment que des avantages
performance puissance autonomie
excellent photos très très très très bon
en vidéo un excellent produit un
excellent cru une fois de plus je vais
regretter ce design so 2010 est à
l'avant heureusement 2019 nous ramène un
petit peu la réalité et dans le monde
actuel alors après ce smartphone
il ya plein davantage mais aussi un très
gros défaut c'est sa politique tarifaire
c'est pas quelque chose d'extrêmement
nouveau on s'en doutait un peu ça coûte
toujours très très très cher mais là
regardez bien quelques cerveaux
smartphone qu'une certification ip68 qui
vous protégera contre lourau la
poussière il faut quand même savoir en
version 64 gigaoctets de stockage qui
est assez peu en fait c'est pas la
nation je vous conseille il coûte 1200
59 euros ça fait mal ça fait très très
mal la version que je vous conseille qui
est intéressante c'est la version 256
giga qui coûte mille 429 euros on est
presque 1500 mal bordel et après vous
avez la version 512 gia qui par contre
est carrément cool à 1629 neurologue là
les prix soient roll c'est la folie ça
reste cher c'est apple on sait alors
après le truc qui peut être intéressant
c'est que si vous aviez effectivement
déjà un iphone si vous et notamment
l'iphone dit son iphone 17 10 s max et
bien vous pouvez leur vendre vous en
tire toujours un bon prix et à ce moment
là comme il ya très peu de décote les
pouvoir en tirer de l'argent pour
investir dans de nouveaux produits mois
note si vous avez déjà un smartphone de
l'année dernière qui est très bon 9 au
17 max je vois pas l'intérêt d'aller là
dessus même si celui là est excellent
j'écoute quand même beaucoup d'argent
tout ça voilà c'est tout moi qui me fait
un petit peu râler c'est que on est sur
un produit qui est vraiment très très
bon qui fait plein de belles promesses
qui les tient qui est vraiment cool
si vous aimez eyeos si vous voulez un
iphone et bien c'est un excellent
produit par contre y'a va falloir vous
saignez il va falloir sortir la mode et
il n'y a pas qu'apple effectivement qu'à
des tarifs qui commence qui augmente de
plus en plus il ya beaucoup de marques
il ya aussi beaucoup de technologies
si beaucoup d'innovations qui a
probablement aussi une marge à respecter
j'imagine que tous les composants coûte
cher apple a pas vous sortir un iphone
au rabais avec des composants moins cher
pour tirer les prix d'un bar c'est
plutôt la halle un verre spécial
vraiment sur le haut du panier sur le
maxi maxi maxi premium mais en face de
ça vous avez un rendu qui est vraiment
extrêmement qualitatif a vous de me dire
mais quand vous ce que vous en pensez
comment vous les trouvez ça il faut de
cette année et comment vous trouvez cet
iphone 11 promax par rapport à l'iphone
11 qui marche déjà très très bien qui
est aussi une super stabilisation de ce
que vous allez faire une vidéo qui est
très bon sur la photo ne lui coûtera son
smartphone qui permet vraiment bien il
ya une différence de prix entre les deux
quand même assez significative vous êtes
à 1200 euros à lens et à 809 euros
après c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose on n'a pas le même techno je vous
renvoie à mon test de l'iphone 11 pour
tout savoir
dites moi ce que vous pensez en tout cas
de cet iphone 11 pro mac c'est ce que
vous pourriez vous en tout cas lâcheté
qu'est ce que vous pensez des
innovations qui sont faites est ce que
vous pensez que apple innove
est-ce que vous pensez que apple se
repose sur ses lauriers qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ça est ce que votre oeil
si habitués ou pas du tout a vous de me
dire tout ça en bas en commentaire quant
à nous on se retrouve dès demain
chanceux vous je vous embrasse les gros
becs qui pue n'oubliez pas si vous
intéresse vous avez les liens en bas
dans la description à demain 10 ou 15